in the case of Thomas Drake represented
attorney
in the relationship between the
executive branch of government that
stands over the intelligence agencies
and the actual ordinary Americans who
comprise the workers of those agencies
from day one when you enter on duty at
any of these places you are it's beaten
into you again and again in policy
training in repeated training
requirements that if you see something
that's illegal
you see something that's
unconstitutional waste fraud abuse you
have to stand up and say something you
have not just the right but the
obligation to try to correct those
improper activities
and despite that here we had a guy who
did absolutely everything right he
placed his faith in the system he saw
you know the wordless wiretapping of
hundreds of millions of Americans
he saw the corruption and procurement
processes and standards adoptions and
things like that he brought it to the IG
he brought it to Congress and rather
than protecting him against retaliation
from some low-level manager letter they
actively retaliated against him in the
the most public an aggressive way to
send a message to everybody in the work
force that things are different now
what matters less is what's right and
wrong and what matters more is who
ordered it we no longer had a system in
the intelligence agencies that was based
on righting wrongs at the lowest level
an instead transition to a system where
when you see something wrong you know
the advice that you get is that's above
your paygrade you need to not worry
about that it doesn't matter whether or
not it looks unconstitutional or
unlawful to you because somebody
somewhere said this is okay and you
simply have to accept that and
that lesson that the system is broken is
something that everybody at every desk
in every agency internalized immediately
we all understood the shift you know we
could feel the wind changing and that
included myself it's fair to say that if
there hadn't been a Thomas Drake there
couldn't been an Edward Snowden
and I think as we move into the future
until this changes until this these
structures are reformed the the next
whistleblower you know the next person
to stand up in real illegal activity
is probably going to learn the same
lessons
when I realized what was going on with
mass surveillance and in my own
experience tried to bring it forward and
get somebody to address these concerns I
encountered a very very different world
from always talks wasn't raining every
colleague that I discussed this with
everybody in my supervisory chain
everybody in the leadership who saw
these things said wow you know that is a
problem that doesn't seem right there
seems like we've sort of gone too far
here and then immediately follow up with
but look you really don't want to get
involved in this you know that's not
your job
let this be somebody else's problem if
you put your name on this they're going
to destroy you and I think there's a
tragedy in that particularly by how
systemic it became now in the wake of
Thomas Drake how this became part of the
institutional culture in 2014 a year
after sort of I went public and the
debate about the the operation of mass
surveillance domestically in the United
States began the Inspector General the
NSA at the time George
Ellard did an interview with the press
where he said you know he really wished
I had come to him because what he
weren't done was he would have made sure
that none of this saw daylight he would
have told me that I just didn't
understand the programs that these were
completely lawful they were completely
constitutional in that you know we could
we can tamp this down we could make sure
that nobody hears about this and all
move on and continue with business as
usual and I would have a very successful
career you know as long as I sat in
place and kept my mouth shut but in 2015
those cases had finally been litigating
the court and the court said that George
Ellery was completely wrong the
Inspector General who said these
programs were constitutional and nobody
should say anything about them said that
not only were they likely
unconstitutional they were Orwellian and
still
they were comprehensively unlawful they
had to be stopped in Congress which is
the biggest cheerleader for the NSA no
country agreed they actually shut down
the program and prohibited the NSA from
collecting Americans communications in
this way the questions that linger most
powerfully for me about the Tom Drake
case and the comments of you know the
NSA Inspector General and the DOJ and
everybody who's institutionalized this
this war on whistleblowers is that if
the institutions that are meant to
curtail the unlawful or unconstitutional
operations of government instead become
complicit in suppressing them what does
that mean for the future where do we go
they later told me in very antiseptic
language we knew when you left in the
morning we knew when you arrived we knew
where you stopped when you shocked
we knew everywhere you went mr. Drake